welcome to folding ideas I'm your host
the foldable human we've talked before
about how failure fits into video games
is games but right now I want to take
that idea and step even further back
looking at games as a medium and art
form there are those in the collective
culture who claim that video games are
not and cannot ever be art they're wrong
of course but why are they wrong there's
a lot of reasons but the one that I want
to focus on right now is this concept
here that by giving control to the
audience you undermine the narrative
integrity of the artwork when you sit
down to watch a film everyone in the
theater is shown the same thing a book
contains the same words and painting as
the same brush strokes games on the
other hand allow for vastly differing
physical experiences the first time I
played ICO it took me a little over 14
hours the second time it took me only
two my sister started but she never
finished on the surface this seems like
a valid observation then movies don't
allow you to spend 30 minutes wandering
around shooting blue portals at every
surface trying to figure out where to go
I mean could you imagine Chinatown with
an extra half-hour of Geddes getting
lost trying to find an address the pace
of the film would be destroyed and the
ultimate meaning and impact would be
diluted it would cease to be the perfect
movie and would become that movie where
the main character gets lost for half
the runtime so pacing and structure are
certainly important elements of
narrative that much is true
or is it okay I agree that it's an
incredibly important element but I'm
going to suggest that it's not a
universal element different media and
genres place different demands on pacing
structure and flow for a moment we're
going to have to go back to one of my
favorite subjects language language is
more than just what you find in a
dictionary
it's the all-encompassing mechanics of
communication you can communicate an
idea with words for sure but you can
also use facial expressions body
language color light contrast and
hundreds of other techniques that form
the backbone of dozens of genres and
mediums if there's communication the
transmission of ideas then there is
language if the audience doesn't
understand the language
then there's a failure of communication
so this idea that games are weaker
because the audience can fail isn't
actually unique to games because books
painting photography television and
movies can all fail to communicate in
their own ways let's get the most
obvious out of the way spoken or written
language if you don't speak the regional
language a film or book is written in
then you probably won't understand it
oh sure you might get the gist of it for
film at least where the overall language
is so much more than just the spoken
dialogue but if you don't speak 17th
century Spanish then you're probably not
going to get very far into it Ignacio
Hidalgo Don Quixote de la Mancha before
you give up but this extends even deeper
than capital L languages there's a
massive online trend of niche and genre
film book and television reviewers who
are proving that the inherent language
of film isn't as inherent as it seems
what makes a great art film isn't the
same as what makes a great action film
the language of schlocky horror isn't
the same as the language of cheesy
comedy the pacing gags blocking lighting
music and mimetic shorthand are all
different
if you can't adjust to the recursive and
broadly referencing language of
something like adaptation then the movie
is going to be an unwatchable mess if
you don't understand solipsism then the
gnawing uncertainty and madness that
builds throughout broken flowers won't
even register in the entire film will
just look like Bill Murray being sort of
funny in a really really awkward way as
a musical example if you have never
dealt with crushing depression then the
Barenaked Ladies pinch me is just a
catchy tune with some odd lyrics I feel
fine enough I guess
considering and great things amass this
capacity for miscommunication is
probably the most dramatic in the still
mediums a viewer can stare at a painting
or photograph for seconds minutes or
hours completing the mechanical
observation and yet still never
understand what it was they were looking
at or why it was interesting this is
most obvious in social or political art
as these pieces typically require
extensive explanation in order to get a
modern viewer up to speed with the
language of the piece maybe what makes
it interesting isn't all that obvious to
start it's like Andy Warhol's art it's
been around so long at this point that
you have to take a step back to remember
a time when it was special and people
really weren't too sure what to do with
it so yeah context is a factor to all of
this is language that goes into the
communication of the ideas and intense
and without that shared language the
viewer can fail they may stay in the
theater until the credits roll they may
stay awake until the end but they've
still sat and spun their mental tires
for a bit making no progress towards the
actual conclusion failure is no more
unique to videogames than color is to
painting in addition to that the
possibility of vastly different physical
experiences isn't unique either looking
at my ICO example from earlier I was
able to finish the game two different
times 14 hours the first time two hours
the second my sister never finished
compared to film this seems obscene
Chinatown 30 minutes of driving around
pacing you know all that that we talked
about earlier that'd be a pretty damning
point if film was the only narrative
media out there but what about books we
still consider pacing to be important in
literature even though the time it takes
to read a book can be pretty extreme
from person to person it took me almost
10 months to work my way through lame is
the first time I read The Giver it took
me a couple of weeks reading at a half
hour or more at a time the fourth or
fifth time I read it it took me maybe
four hours cover to cover but we still
talk about books as being well or poorly
paced even if it takes one person hours
longer to get through 50 pages than it
takes someone else okay so if there's
all these similarities
between video games and film and
literature and photography and painting
and music then why is there any
controversy at all
well because there are differences but
in my mind this is where we start to get
into the really cool stuff
video games bring in new vectors for
interaction and communication basically
new forms of language that merge the
capabilities of other mediums in video
games the mechanics of playing the gamer
is much a part of the language as the
dialogue music art and pacing one of the
best examples of this is the
first-person shooter now at first glance
it may seem that the first-person games
would be the easiest for new players to
pick up but they're actually one of the
hardest first-person games rely on very
specific conventions in their control
scheme a vocabulary of commands if you
will using one hand to steer the feet
while using the other to steer the head
and torso that kind of spatial
abstraction is surprisingly difficult
for new players to master while
incredibly intuitive for people who
already know it you know like a language
this language element becomes incredibly
obvious if you go back and play the
early versions of complicated genres
like realtime strategy games games like
Warcraft orcs and humans are doomed to
lack many of the control options that
we've become used to and trying to play
them these days is like trying to
explain insanity wolf to your
grandparents it's a communication
problem beyond that the natural
extension of mechanics are the choices
they represent and the consequences of
those choices this folds back into the
whole discussion of failure the ability
to fail is intrinsic to communication
and more than other media games allow us
to explore that failure in novel ways
how do we respond to challenges
incentives and options how do we solve
problems so let's go back to that
original question
some people say video games aren't art
they're wrong why are they wrong well
because the entire basis of their
argument is wrong they're framing it as
a one or the other argument which just
isn't the case literature isn't going
anywhere neither is motion picture music
or graphic art interactive art
complements and in many ways borrows
from and uses these other medium
the same as they trade back and forth
between each other interactive art also
opens up avenues of exploration and
questioning that other media just can't
do as well the funny thing is that these
opponents of video games seem to know
this already interactive exhibits have
been commonplace in fine art galleries
for decades and were hardly unheard of
prior to that exhibits that allowed
participants to throw paint at a while
write their name break plates or
reposition performers if that's art then
why not ICO elitism and ignorance plain
and simple
there are old people who don't share the
language and see the target market is
full of undesirables you know for a
complex issue it at least has a really
simple answer
you
you